you know Shania she knows something
about competition shows because tonight
is episode two should I use new show
real country on USA and you're actually
both executive producer and a panelist
so I want to know because you know I
love me some country music you know that
Shania I want to know what inspired your
new show which both this is solely on
country music well I'm very passionate
about what I love the difference in the
fact that it is genre specific it's
about country we've got so many great
artists out there that need to be
discovered we have to make room for them
especially for diversity we need to make
room for diversity oh we need more women
we need basically we have to take
advantage of all the different styles
that fall under country music so it's my
passion real country you know what you
do it and what a good John retur because
it just keeps coming more and more
popular oh it's a it's I mean just the
history of country music alone we forget
so many of our great music legends or
country music artists that's true and
you know uh
Shania well as she had her time on the
boys and American Idol so did your time
there did it prepare you for this show
helped you in some way it gave me the
bug we've never seemed like angry yet
but we are he's gonna get mad are you
gonna take him on now are you gonna I
love it man but you've been sexiest
woman alive and I know your tour is
almost coming to an end but just right
for Christmas I know um the last leg of
my tour is coming up in a few days I'm
going off to Australia New Zealand and
I'll make it home on the 24th how are
you gonna do the misma shopping I'm not
well the president will just be because
great a great the trio yeah well I do
want to know what you're gonna do do you
do all the cooking or what do you do for
free well I do love to cook I my
speciality is gravy I can never have
enough gravy yeah but I can't imagine
that you still have this figure when you
eat a lot of gravy
oh that's impressive we want to know
that trick yeah yeah oh my god there's
no trick
I guess Spanx that's always a good way
that's like a trick for me I eat a lot
of variety and just not
much quantity I don't know I don't know
I don't always follow my best advice but
yeah we're a lot of things with elastic
waist I hear ya I don't think you need
it but I hear what you're talking about
all right well Shania is not going
anywhere because we are gonna have a lot
of fun with some of your classics oh I
don't think she knows about it we have a
little surprise for her - coming up
[Music]
[Applause]